un coup de coeur pour vous êtes rentré
vous avez deux enfants vous avez une
très belle carrière et pourtant tout a
basculé pour vous depuis quelques années
vous battez pour sauver votre fils
Arthur de la drogue tout a commencé
quand Arthur était âgé de 19 ans il
venait d'avoir son bac qui vit dans un
studio avec sa petite amie et là il a il
a complètement plongé dans la rue il
dévisse ouais enfin il commence il avait
commencé à fumer assez tôt des pétards
du cannabis au collège vers 15 ans c'est
important de le dire ça et en fait alors
les médecins disent souvent le truc
est-ce qu'elle a toi c'est à dire qui
fume un œuf fume un buzz par exemple moi
j'ai pu constater qu'effectivement à
chaque fois il est allé crescendo c'est
ça de plus en plus loin après il y a eu
les drogues de synthèse donc type MDMA
et puis quelque chose de très couru pour
les jeunes notamment en boîte ou pour
les concerts qui est de la kétamine qui
est un
anesthésiant pour chevaux
et ça ça fait des dégâts terribles
neurologiques et lui il a fait sa
première bouffée délirante parce que
avec sa petite copine
[Musique]
aussi pardon ce drogué aussi il a pris
là il a acheté des champignons
hallucinogènes sur sur Internet et là il
les a cultivés chez lui il en prenait
pendant un mois un mois et demi et
jusqu'au pétage de plomb c'était quoi
son état alors comment il a pété les
plombs il a pété les plombs un jour il a
je le voyais il passait des coups de fil
tard je passe à 5h du matin en disant
n'importe quoi et donc quand j'essaie de
le rappeler le lendemain il répond pas
et
en fait il a disparu il est pas chez lui
on arrive chez lui il y avait écrit
Merci sur le mur la porte ouverte
donc là un peu paniqué quand même et on
met du temps à le retrouver parce que
les ben vous faites les commissariats et
les commissariats de non non on a
personne etc donc finalement on a fini
par le retrouver avec un petit coup de
piston
de quelqu'un qu'on connaissait
finalement on le retrouve au
commissariat où il était alors les
policiers ont cru qu'il avait bu enfin
ils sont pas cherché à savoir ils l'ont
emmené à l'hôpital et puis finalement il
a il a il a pourri dans sa cellule de
dégrisement pendant toute la journée il
avait déchiré ses vêtements il s'était
griffé enfin il était c'était quelqu'un
d'autre alors il avait des accès de
folie et des stratagèmes pour se payer
cette drogue il vous a volé oui
il m'a volé des bijoux ah oui
il a revendu
pour sous l'influence de quelqu'un
d'assez nauséabond parce qu'il y a
toujours autour parce que ça
on fait c'est plutôt un garçon assez
très émotif très très hypersensible et
surtout influençable et donc voilà les
mauvaises fréquentations c'est sa petite
copine c'est quoi
il va jamais enfin il veut pas dire les
choses
pour toujours on va dire mais il allait
souvent vers les gens peu recommandables
alors un jour jusqu'à vous accuser de
deux choses terribles
oui parce que en fait le la drogue ça
modifie l'état de conscience fortement
c'est à dire que vous avez
quelqu'un qui n'est plus la personne que
vous connaissez après il redevient tout
à fait normal gentil
intelligent cultivé et d'un seul coup il
se transforme en diable en espèce de
double personnalité
dans sa folie il dit des choses
terribles dans le livre du style oui
parce que
il me demande de l'argent et je il est à
l'hôpital à l'époque et pour s'acheter
des bonbons je sais pas quoi il y a un
moment on dit non ça suffit stop il me
dit de toute façon
voilà tu m'as tripoté quand j'étais
petit je le dirai à tout le monde
donc là je raconte ça dans le livre
parce que
du pâté ça on peut régler non non mais
c'est sûr mais non mais c'est incroyable
ce que vous dites mais c'est quoi votre
ex pardon votre action
on est en train de ranger son studio
parce qu'on rend son studio parce qu'il
était à l'hôpital et qu'on va pas payer
à du thème eternam un studio et donc il
est pas d'accord et et voilà et je lui
donne une gifle à ce moment-là quand il
me dit ça tu as pas le droit de donc je
regrette aussitôt
je tends un billet de 20 euros pour
qu'il rentre à la clinique qui prennent
un taxi et là je m'écroule sur le sol de
son appartement et je et là je peux pas
me relever pendant une heure je suis je
suis je suis vaincu quoi
il va comment aujourd'hui
ça va il va beaucoup mieux
[Musique]
mais il a une incapacité à travailler
parce que il stresse très très vite donc
moi le message important que j'ai envie
de dire je suis pas là pour faire la
mère Fouettard maman
je de là où je parle c'est d'une maman
qui a vécu ça et j'ai des milliers
franchement des milliers de témoignages
de parents qui ne savent plus quoi faire
parce que on ne sait pas quelle porte
pousser il y a pas de prévention la
psychiatrie et le parent pauvre de la
médecine tout le monde le sait et
ça crée des enfin ça révèle des
problèmes psychiatriques soit des
énormes dépression soit des bipolarités
ou de la schizophrénie la plupart du
temps donc ce n'est pas anodin
voilà il y a le pétard récréatif mais ça
peut même une bouffée peut parfois
déclencher il a lu le livre oui
bien sûr
le livre de roselina qu'on voit derrière
voilà très très important et je sais
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens ont
genre de problème essaie de plus en plus
fréquents et n'oubliez pas ce qu'elle a
dit au départ ça a commencé par des
joints et puis et souvent on laisse
passer des choses et vous les voilà et
c'est après ça ça devient beaucoup plus
grave il y a de plus en plus de cas
comme celui de de Roselyne